[Music]
are you a good girl
you're a dirty little girl
[Music]
who's in charge here what the hell do
you want at my crime scene we're the fbi
i'm with the state police give me a
shout i'm supposed to be protecting
these girls it's not your operation
you belong to me you understand what i'm
saying
now lift up that skirt no
the minute i got made bait it became my
operation
i have communication with over a dozen
active offenders
we had a bonafide serial killer
i got a girl with a skull cracked in six
places the bite marks
it matches
another girl vanished from a truck stop
outside pensacola last night
stop there who's that
get up it's purification time
who was he tried to cuff one of my girls
he had a lightning bolt on his truck
he's hurting some girl right now
i can set him up again
you sure if you look familiar
not never get such a pretty face
cheers
she promised me this is gonna be bad
hello somebody there
do everything that you can to get out
where
folks may live alone i just want to keep
an eye out for you
you're gonna get me killed we'll have a
little party
don't you worry we'll have our time
[Music]
together
[Music]
you